getting the homeless vaccinated should
be a priority
one of society's most transient groups
exposed to covert in crowded shelters
and at risk of complications if infected
charities are reaching out
[Music]
[Music]
increasingly mobile in the summer the
homeless need the support of europe
cities now more than ever
[Music]
welcome i'm ben fazoulen well that
support varies from city to city as
we'll discuss soon and it's access to
vaccines that's often the hurdle for the
homeless but as our reporter yuri
rashetto found out an initiative in
saint petersburg is reaching out to
those living on the streets
vithyak knows this street well he's
homeless and prefers not to give his
full name
every morning he comes here to seven
mirgarotsky street behind the beautiful
facades in the center of saint
petersburg
hot meals are served here daily today
video and his 30 or so friends from the
street are also getting their first dose
of sputnik v russia's vaccine against
covet 19. there is a small gift too some
hygiene items to take away as a thank
you
the gift will eventually run out but the
vaccination will stay
a local charity organized the
vaccination drive with a couple of saint
petersburg doctors they say it's long
overdue
an estimated 60 000 people live on the
streets of saint petersburg a city of 5
million where the coronavirus is
spreading fast nearly 2 000 new cases
are registered here daily that's the
second highest rate in russia after
moscow
homeless people are just normal patients
who also get sick and get covert 19.
but what makes homeless people different
from others is that they often don't
have papers and can't identify
themselves
and in russia just like everywhere else
echovit 19 vaccination has to be
officially registered
so volunteers are helping to establish
the patient's identity
your consent form
but it doesn't work for all of them some
don't even know their names still the
helpers say this shouldn't stop people
getting vaccinated
the situation with covert 19 means that
everyone in russia needs to get
vaccinated regardless of whether they
have their ids with them right now or
not
it all takes a couple of hours the
vaccination is voluntary the mood
relaxed
it's good for me and means i won't
infect the others
i've already had my vaccination i've had
all the vaccinations i'm just here to
get something to eat
today's lunch is mashed potatoes and a
piece of white bread
we chose this place because people come
here for food anyway so we didn't have
to give them advance notice about the
vaccinations
meanwhile has also gotten his lunch
he's been living on the streets for
three years and says he's happy
[Laughter]
in exactly 21 days time vitiok and the
others will get their second dose of
sputnik v
they already know exactly where to come
so should the homeless be prioritized
let's talk about that with
epidemiologist thomas jordara he joins
us from paris
where should the homeless be placed on
vaccine priority lists in your opinion
hello
thanks for uh inviting me um that's uh
that's a tricky question if you
um in terms of numbers of potential
cases etc maybe the homeless people are
not the
the highest priority for for a nation of
our government but in terms of
uh shattering over protecting
the most vulnerable people they should
be they should be as high as
the elderly people etcetera to my
opinion
that's uh just to just to avoid having
uh having uh
high fatality or high number of cases in
this population exactly according to
some doctors i've read that homeless
people with covert are five times more
likely to be admitted to intensive care
units and eight times more likely to die
exactly uh in a recent systematic review
and or meta analysis
i think it was published in clinical
medicine
that was really summarizing all the
studies and all the reports that have
been done on homeless
people's people
uh yes
even though i have to nuance this a bit
because there has not been that many
studies so it still needs to be
studied more but yes they have they are
they have more risk of having uh
hospitalization and they are they are
more at risk of dying uh
yeah because of several uh several
factors
i guess um for example yeah
sorry so go through those factors for me
that's something important that people
should know
yes so um
for the people who are not super aware
of the of the conditions of leading of
the homeless so you can have people
living in the streets but you have also
people uh sharing uh shelters uh having
to go from one less to another so in
terms of career in terms of epidemic
epidemic wise they are they are more at
risk
than the rest of the population because
they have to go find their own food they
have to go
in several places to uh to find food to
find the
accommodation etc so they are exposing
themselves just by having to having to
go around
and also they have more commodities in
general
depending if they are if they are recent
migrants or if they are only sitting in
the streets for a long time they can
have also
several diseases linked to due to age
they can be
they can be they can have diabetes
diabetes hypertension hybrid pressure
etc
a bit more i don't know if you can say a
lot more of a bit more interested in the
rest of the population and thomas age
mostly determines where you are on
vaccine lists but homeless people in
their 30s 40s 50s often have health
problems typically found in much older
people don't they
yes yes you can find you can find some
diseases such as diabetes for example
you know 30 or 40 years old living in
the streets so indeed the age the age
criteria shouldn't be the only one to to
decide who to vaccinate and i don't know
for other countries but in france it's
not the only criteria it's also the the
the fact the risk factors that should be
uh that should be also studied even
though it hasn't been really a criteria
that had been super well followed in
france for example age was really the
domain the main the main factor the main
criteria to get vaccinated so yeah for
homeless people it's uh it's a double
it's a double burden it's uh they are
not in uh they are not a priority in
general as homeless people and also they
tend to be a bit younger and to not fit
the criteria to get to to get a vaccine
even so it's changing of course
it doesn't seem like they're a priority
either in this in this pandemic um where
you are the homeless are in the fourth
or fifth phase of the rollout in other
countries like hungary for example
they're in the second phase why is the
picture so mixed in europe
um i think it's uh it has to do with uh
with the sort of things that politics of
course but it's also you have to do
choices and also
it's one thing to say i would like to
see the reality for hungary or russia
for example unlike in your in your
in your documentary uh you have to find
people who
want to go to vaccinate and how to
vaccinate homeless people and migrants
in france it has been a challenge the
authorities
they decided to
to change the the the priority for
homeless people but they didn't have the
capacity to uh to go and find and and
then and convince homeless people to get
vaccinated so in the end they have to
rely on ngos and uh and organizations to
do the workforce i don't know it is for
other countries but in in france it's
not the the willingness it's not the
yeah what they were saying we should we
should prioritize uh prioritize homeless
people but in reality
[Music]
it was not happening
and so yeah it's only recently that uh
ngos and organizations have been
vaccinating homeless and migrants in the
streets
uh and at
a high uh yeah at a high speed
okay we'll have to leave it there thomas
from doctors without right thank you
very much for being on the show today
thank you very much have a good day
time to hand you over to dw science
correspondent derek williams with
another viewer question
if you catch the delta variant are the
symptoms different
information on the delta variant is at
times confusing with with different
studies on how it compares to earlier
versions of the virus
regularly reporting contradictory
results but but hey that's just how
science works consensus building takes
time
what pretty much everyone agrees on so
far
is that the delta variant is a lot more
transmissible
than the ancestral form of the virus
people who get it
are almost twice as contagious
one preprint study indicates that could
be because patients who contract delta
that they might also be producing a lot
more of the virus and and a lot faster
than earlier variants
the question of whether delta causes
different symptoms in patients however
and in particular whether it causes more
severe disease
that's still kind of open
to try to answer it a lot of researchers
have looked at data from britain where
the delta variant has really dominated
the covet landscape
for some time now
one wide scale app-based study there
that over time has tracked symptoms
reported by british patients
it indicates that they might indeed be
somewhat different for delta on average
participant responses they're changed
with the advent of delta and now they're
reporting a lot more cold-like symptoms
such as sore throat or runny nose
like dry cough and losing your sense of
smell on the other hand which are
commonly caused by other variants those
are now being reported a lot less often
on the app
other studies have linked the delta
variant to other more severe symptoms
and increased rates of hospitalization
but but the jury is still out on that
thanks for watching
you